willkommen zu ZDF heute live seit
Monaten verteidigt die ukrainische Armee
die Kleinstadt bachmut im Osten des
Landes gegen die russischen Angreifer
und damit ist dieser Ort auch längst zu
einem Symbol dieses Krieges geworden
noch hält die zahlenmäßig weit
unterlegene Ukraine stand aber sie zahlt
ein sehr hohen Preis denn auf beiden
Seiten sterben täglich zahlreiche
Soldaten manche Quellen sprechen von
hunderten auf beiden Seiten täglich und
auch wenn auch deutlich mehr Russen als
Ukrainer fallen wird trotzdem Kritik an
der ukrainischen Entscheidung laut die
Stadt zu halten ja sollte diese Taktik
aufgegeben werden welche Bedeutung hat
bachmut militärisch aus symbolisch in
diesem Krieg und was wären die Folgen
eines ukrainischen Rückzugs über diese
und weitere Aspekte wollen wir heute
sprechen und diskutieren wir freuen uns
natürlich wie immer auf eure Fragen eure
Kommentare wie immer gern an uns per
Mail oder über Social Media außerdem
sprechen wir mit dem Militär perten und
oberstedt Wolfgang Richter und davor mit
dem ukrainischen Kriegsreporter Ilja
Porno marenko von der Zeitung Kiew
independent der seit Kriegsbeginn aus
dem Osten des Landes berichtet und die
Geschehnisse und die Atmosphäre an der
Front auch aus eigenem Erleben kennt
doch zuvor gibt uns meinen Kollege
Antoine einen Überblick über die
aktuelle Situation in bachmut
ob in der Luft
am Boden
oder im Häuserkampf die Ukraine kämpft
weiter um bachmut seit sieben Monaten
ein Kampf mit hohen Verlusten auf beiden
Seiten drohnenbilder zeigen das Ausmaß
der Zerstörung der strategisch wichtigen
Stadt in der Ostukraine sie gehört zur
Verteidigungslinie in der Region dann
jetzt
würde bahmut fallen könnten die Russen
weiter Richtung kramertors und Florians
vordringen um das zu erschweren haben
die Ukrainer Brücken rund um bachmut
zerstört
wir müssen sie besiegen
mehr noch wir müssen ihnen in den Arsch
treten und sie nach Hause jagen
der Feind aber rückt immer näher ins
Stadtzentrum ganz vorne mit dabei die
Söldnergruppe Wagner die für die Russen
kämpft wir mussten die Häuser zerstören
um überhaupt an sie heranzukommen denn
die Scharfschützen waren in fast jedem
Gebäude
der Kampf um bachmut ist auch eine
Materialschlacht es gibt Berichte über
Nachschub Probleme die Munition wird
knapp die Ukraine hoffen dringend auf
die Leopard-Kampfpanzer aus dem Westen
alle hier warten darauf auch meine
Brigade erst vor kurzem haben wir unsere
Leute zur Ausbildung am Leopard 2 A6
geschickt
die Schlacht um bachmut sie ist jetzt
schon die längste und blutigste im
ukrainekrieg
und mit uns verbunden in der Nähe von
Butcher ist jetzt
Ilja Polo marenko ukrainischer
Kriegsreporter für die Zeitung Kiew
independent erstmal einen guten Abend
hallo
guten Abend
sie haben dieser Tage Herr Bruno marenko
einen Tweet abgesetzt und dazu muss man
sagen sie sind ja nicht irgendein
Reporter sondern sie haben bei Twitter
1,2 Millionen Follower etwa und haben
sie geschrieben i hope wie crainian
command really really really knows what
is doing in bachmood also ich hoffe die
ukrainische Militärführung weiß wirklich
was sie da tut in bachmut wie gesagt sie
haben eine große Reichweite sind ein
Chronist des Krieges in ihrem Land und
es klingt ein wenig so als hätten sie
zumindest Zweifel daran dass es sinnvoll
ist bachmut weiter unter allen Umständen
zu verteidigen stimmt das
ja jeder in der Ukraine hat natürlich
Zweifel in Bezug auf Paket es gibt viele
die dafür sind viele dagegen es gibt
viele Fragen man weiß nicht was dabei
rauskommt
konventionell sagt man natürlich
ja und das gilt auch für alle
ernsthaften Bericht hat die sagen es
wäre vernünftig zu verlassen bevor es zu
spät ist das zu Todesfalle
aber gleichzeitig
wissen wir natürlich dass das die
ukrainische Heeresführung gesagt hätte
sollen weiter im Bach Boot verteidigen
und weiterhin die garision
unterstützen die unter schwierigen
Bedingungen und die Stadt hält obwohl
die eingekehrt werden können das ist
eine tourismusfalle ist also
konventionell würde man sagen
dass die ukrainische Organisation
zurückgezogen hätte werden sollen um
Leben zu retten
gleichzeitig ist der Krieg natürlich
sehr kompliziert es gibt so viele
Antworten auf das was sich da gerade tut
tatsächlich
wissen wir nicht wirklich was die
ukrainischen Reserven sind was der Plan
der Heeresführung ist wir wissen nur
dass die Stadt und die Garnison dort in
einer gefährlichen Situation verbleibt
der Zugang zu diesem Bereich
des hunderte der ist nur wenige hundert
Meter breit und der Nachschub wird ja
eng kontrolliert von den Russen also die
Russen hätten die Stadt schon vor langem
einnehmen können
denkt man irgendwann werden man dachte
eigentlich im Januar würden die Russen
die Stadt einketzen dann eben Februar
dann im März und jetzt sind wir in der
Mitte vom März und die Schlacht geht
weiter und die Macht die Russen machen
kleiner aber
inkrementelle zu gewinnen um die Stadt
einzukesseln die öffentliche Meinung ist
geteilt dass Militär schickt jetzt die
besten Truppen dahin um an dieser
Operation teilzunehmen
und
die besten Einheiten
kämpfen dort und man glaubt dann sie
die generelle haben bisher gezeigt dass
in der Lage sind die notwendigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen in schwierigen
Situationen das gab es auch schon bei
der Schlacht von cerodonetzk und anderen
kämpfen andere Situationen
wo man auf kleinerer Ebene die richtigen
Entscheidungen getroffen hat ich würde
gerne noch mal kurz einhaken
wenn das möglich ist
danke erstmal für diese Schilderung Sie
persönlich waren ja um neuer das letzte
Mal in bachmut wie lässt sich die
Situation aus eigenem Erleben dort
beschreiben
[Musik]
da gibt es sehr viel Verzweiflung sehr
viel Blut sehr viele Emotionen unter den
ukrainischen Verteidigern aber man spürt
auch den Motor und die Entschlossenheit
und immer wieder passieren Dinge in der
Stadt ich habe eine Zeit mit der 24
begrate der Artillerie verbracht und bei
der Artillerie der geht es so bestimmte
Mechanismen trotz aller Probleme trotz
des Todes trotz des verzweifelnden
Mangels an Munition
arbeiten die wirklich wie ein Uhrwerk
die kämpft werden Uhrwerk und das
gleiche gilt für die Infanterie in der
Stadt aber es gibt sehr viel
Verzweiflung und gleichzeitig
Entschlossenheit und die Soldaten dort
die sind natürlich bitter
die beschweren sich über das blutige
kämpfenden Mangel an Nachschub und sie
beschweren sich über quandeure
oder
über die hat den Verlauf der Schlacht wo
sie praktisch Zeit kaufen für die
Ukraine mit ihrem Blut mit ihrem Leben
gleichzeitig akzeptieren Sie dass Sie
diese Arbeit tun müssen und
sie sagen dass sie nicht einfach sterben
wollen sie wollen kämpfen
nicht sie kaufen leben sie kaufen Zeit
mit ihrem Leben mit ihrem Blut und um
Weihnachten rum war die Stadt schon halb
umzingelt von den russischen Kräften und
die russischen Kräfte
die Waren im Süden Norden und Ost aber
nicht in der Stadt und dann wurde die
Stadt sehr stark beschädigt in vielen
Bereichen viele Häuser wurden zerstört
aber es war
immer noch so dass das also sehr viel
zerstört war oder das einiges noch stand
aber jetzt sieht man das bachgut gar
nicht mehr existiert als menschliche
Ansiedlung alles ist zerstört praktisch
genau wir haben gerade auch noch mal die
Bilder gesehen die Stadt ist absolut
bestehend aus Ruinen im Prinzip nur noch
trotzdem vielleicht noch mal die Frage
militärisch gesehen aber auch symbolisch
vielleicht auch psychologisch gesehen
was würde denn ein Rückzug der
ukrainischen Truppen ihrer Meinung nach
bedeuten wäre das haben sie Sorge muss
ich Fragen haben sie Sorge dass das ein
Wendepunkt sein könnte psychologisch
gesehen im Krieg ist es deswegen auch so
wichtig die Stadt zu halten
also einer der Gründe
warum man die Stadt halten will ist dass
es eine Festung ist eine der größten
stärksten feste und dieser Region das
ist eine starke Festung
an den wichtigsten Verteidigungslinien
in dieser Region
und das ist natürlich eine
Materialschlacht denn die Russen werfen
alles an Ressourcen ins Feld um die
Stadt zu
umzingeln und sie zu bekommen es ist
natürlich alles sehr gefährlich
und irgendwann kommt natürlich der
Moment
wo man das defensiv Potenzial verliert
was also bachmut angeht
bachmut ist natürlich eine
Heldengeschichte eine Geschichte ist
unglaublichen stolz dass der Ukraine und
man muss dran denken ja dem bitte man
spricht
geht da ich schlachte machen muss seit
August manche sagen es geht schon seit
Mai so dass man da und bachmut kämpft
das ist ja eigentlich nur eine kleine
Stadt und nicht viele Leute kannten nach
Mut vorher überhaupt
die Bedeutung ist das ist eine starke
Festung
und die Russen haben es sehr schwer
gehabt hier fortschrittlich zu machen
und das ist natürlich eine wichtige
Verteidigungslinie
es ist die größte und
härteste Verteidigungslinie rum kann man
Thorsten und das geht bis
dativka und das ist ein ganz wichtige
Verteidigungslinie für die Ukraine aber
man weiß natürlich nicht wie sich die
Heeresführung der entscheidet und
warum sie die besten Einheiten in der
Stadt in der Garnison dort lassen wir
wissen auch nicht was das für
Alternativen gibt um sich zurückzuziehen
auf andere
Verteidigungslinien ob das Sinn ergibt
oder gerechtfertigt ist
man will natürlich so auch die
russischen Einheiten aus bluten und
zusehen dass sie viel Material dort
verwenden
genau wenn ich gerade
ist immer schwierig mit dem Dolmetscher
weil ich versuche es gerade noch mal an
der stelle ich will gerade nur mal ganz
kurz die Kritikpunkte auch vortragen die
es eben gibt auch aus der Ukraine unter
anderem vom militäranalysten Oleg Stan
auf der sagt die Kräfte die jetzt in
bachmut geopfert würden sozusagen würden
eigentlich für eine neue Gegenoffensive
auf die russischen Linien gebraucht das
ist eben einer der Kritikpunkte die
andere Kritik von dem Militärhistoriker
und auch ihrem Namensvetter Roman Roman
Bruno marenko er warnt davor dass in
bachmund eben viele Menschen und
Material zu verlieren drohen verloren zu
gehen drohen sobald die Stadt von
Russland eingekesselt sei besser sei es
sich vorher zurückzuziehen also das nur
mal vielleicht ganz kurz das sind die
Punkte die eben da auch noch im Raum
stehen ich will aber gerne noch auf
einen anderen Punkt mit ihnen zu
sprechen kommen auch vielleicht mehr
persönlich auch was sie betrifft sie
haben auf ihrem Twitter-Account auch
schon den ein oder anderen Gefallenen zu
beklagen gehabt anderen persönlichen
Umfeld das können wir uns vielleicht
gerade auch noch mal anschauen hier
haben wir rest in peace mediciana die
also getötet wurde in im Kampf in der
Nähe von von bachmut also offenbar eine
Sanitäterin dann weiter oben auf Ihrem
Account auch noch mal das rest in peace
an die Metro da Vinci koziopiano ein
relativ hoch dekorierter noch jung an
Jahren aber hoch dekorierter hält der
Ukraine im militärischen also ein
Kommandeur auch eher im Kampf gefallen
also einige auch persönliche Verluste
für sie wie gehen Sie damit um im Moment
das stimmt natürlich dass ich als
Ukrainer wirklich den Überblick verloren
habe über den Menschen die in diesem
Krieg gestorben sind
ich spreche nicht mal über die Zeit
vorher in dombas
viele Ukraine
wie ich es Scrollen auf Facebook und
sehen da Gesichter und Bilder in
schwarz-weiß von Soldaten die getötet
worden sind das passiert was jeden Tag
wie gehen wir damit um
ja wir akzeptieren das einfach es ist
Teil des Krieges
und ganz viele Menschen sind getötet
worden unter den Zivilisten und dem
Militärs das ist ein schrecklicher Preis
den die Nation bezahlt
in unseren Straßen an der Front
und daran werden wir uns noch für viele
Dekaden nach dem Krieg erinnern
aber die Rettung dieses Landes ist
wichtig das motiviert uns weiter zu
machen
wir sind dankbar dass wir diese Menschen
kannten die sich opferten und
eine Nation unter einer solchen
Bedrohung in einem solchen Krieg eine
Nation in so einer Situation muss das
akzeptieren das passiert immer in der
Geschichte leider
wir können dagegen auch nicht zunehmen
im Moment wir wünschen natürlich der
Ukraine dass das möglichst bald vorüber
sein mag ganz herzlichen Dank für dieses
Gespräch Ilja Bruno marenko war das für
uns aus der Nähe von Butcher und
zugeschaltet danke schön und alles Gute
für Sie
ja die ukrainische Militärführung hat
heute noch mal bekräftigt und
beschlossen auch noch mal das an der
Verteidigung von bachmute eben
festzuhalten ist das hat Präsident
selensky vor wenigen Stunden auch noch
mal verkündet bereits davor hatte sich
silensky wie folgt zu den Kämpfen im
Osten des landesgeräusche hat
es ist sehr hart im Osten sehr
schmerzvoll wir müssen die militärische
Kraft des Feindes brechen und wir werden
sie brechen bilo rifka und Marinka auf
die jewka und bachmut wolle da und
kamyanka und an all den anderen Plätzen
entscheidet sich die Zukunft die wir
Ukraine haben werden
und über diese Zukunft unter anderem
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
Militärexperten vor allem aber auch
natürlich über die Gegenwart mit dem
Militärexperten und oberste Wolfgang
Richter ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen
guten Abend Herr Richter hallo
guten Abend ja bachmut halten oder nicht
wir haben gerade die eindrücklichen
Schilderungen gehört aus der Ukraine wie
würden Sie als Militärexperte diese
Frage beantworten
ja zunächst mal für bachmut ein vor
Augen was abnutzungskrieg tatsächlich
bedeutet das ist ein Stellungskampf ein
blutiger Ortskampf in dem jeden Tag
hunderte von Menschen fallen und viele
mehr verwundet werden das gilt für beide
Seiten das ist die schreckliche Wahrheit
dieses Krieges wenn man da eine Ebene
tiefer geht und sich dann die Frage
stellt ja was soll das dann gibt es
natürlich eine rein militärische
Argumente die man anführen kann äh es
wurde auch einige schon ja gesagt von
ihrem auf dem Militär dem ukrainischen
Experten
natürlich kann man sagen es geht darum
aus ukrainischer Sicht Russland Verluste
beizubringen die dann vielleicht später
für die früher als offensive oder die
jetzt beginnen in der Offensive dann
fehlen es geht auch darum Zeit zu kaufen
und die nächste Verteidigungslinie
vorzubereiten aber auch darum um nicht
Gelände zu verlieren für den
ihr angestrebten Fall selbst in die
Gegend Offensive nach Süden zu treten
und dann würde man eine Flanke aufmachen
man darf nicht vergessen ein Durchbruch
bei bachmut das ist ja eine ein eckpfahl
in einer ausgebauten
verteidigungstellung würde bedeuten dass
man dann etwa 30 35 km offenes Gelände
vor sich hat bevor das selbe dann wieder
vor kramert raus ganz labians weitergeht
denn das ist die nächste wirkliche
günstige Stellung wo also Ortschaften ja
da sind die man gut verteidigen kann
aber das wurde eben auch eine große
Gelände Aufgabe bedeuten und mit den
Nachteilen verbunden sein die ich gerade
erwähnt habe dagegen spricht allerdings
das ist in der Tat jetzt so ist das
qualitativ hochwertige
ukrainische Einheiten dorthin geworfen
werden die dann auch hohe Verluste
leiden und sich dann die Frage gestellt
hat man dann noch genügend qualifiziert
das Personal für eine für die eigene
gegen Offensive und das schlimmste
Szenario wäre wenn etwas passiert wenn
Mario Polar das heißt dass diese
Einheiten in bachmut eingeschlossen
werden wir sollten nicht vergessen dass
nördlich und südlich von wachmut
russische Einheiten bereits die Stadt
weit überflügelt haben und weiter nach
Westen vorgedrungen sind das heißt die
Möglichkeit diesen Ring zuzumachen
besteht tatsächlich die Ukrainer müssen
sich dann eben viel einfallen lassen und
genau das zu verhindern mit Artillerie
mit vielleicht auch Gegenangriffen das
kann ich natürlich von dir aus der Ferne
Richter jetzt haben sie schon wahnsinnig
viel Input geliefert ich lese gerade
noch mal 2 Kommentare vor die uns
erreicht haben JPG Games über Youtube
nein die Ukraine muss machen Mut halten
diese Taktik erinnert an die Situation
in Version das Ergebnis kennen wir alle
die Russen haben sich am Ende aus
Version zurückgezogen anderer Meinung
wiederum ist Dagobert Engel Hardy über
Facebook Russland ist doch quantitativ
haushoch überlegen die Ukraine sollten
schnellstmöglich daraus schnellstmöglich
ansonsten werden tausende gefangen
genommen das muss nicht da sein
zurückziehen neu formieren zu seiner
Einschätzung sie haben jetzt gerade
schon Argumente sozusagen für beide
Sichtweisen geliefert ähm Randolf
Armbruster verbindet das ganze mit einer
Frage er fragt hat das Warten auf
westliche Waffenlieferungen einen
Einfluss bachmut erstmal bis auf alles
zu verteidigen wie es ihre Einschätzung
dazu
also alle drei Fragen sind natürlich
sehr valide bei Carson hätte ich
allerdings eine etwas andere Auffassung
der Rückzug aus kerson in die Russen im
November letzten Jahres vorgenommen habe
haben war ein geplanter operativ
notwendiger Rückzug das war in dem Sinn
keine Niederlage politisch ja weil man
natürlich die Gebietshauptstadt eines
Gebietes verloren hat die man gerade
annektiert hatte auf der anderen Seite
war es militärisch geboten man hätte
über den Nepper im Winter da der ist ein
sehr breiter Fluss von einem Kilometer
breite hätte man die Logistik nicht
geschafft aber russischer Sicht das
heißt dieser Gruppen werden
abgeschnitten gewesen das war richtig
sie zurückzuziehen aber es war nicht
dann einstellungskampf so wie wir das
jetzt im Bach mit sehen das gab es
gestern nicht die andere Frage die
zweite diese gestellt haben ist
natürlich zugreifen wenn man die gesamte
Ressourcen sieht die Russland
mobilisiert hat mittlerweile und
vielleicht auch noch andere Sachen
mobilisieren kann sind natürlich den
ukrainischen weit überlegen auf der
anderen Seite muss man auch bedenken und
das Russland dieser Gruppen ja verteilen
muss auf ein riesen Gebiet vom Nordkap
bis zum Kaukasus von den nato-grenzen im
Baltikum bis hin nach Kamtschatka und
dazwischen liegen sehr sehr weite
Gebiete das heißt man kann die nicht
beliebig frei machen insofern sind auch
die russischen Ressourcen die unendlich
aber sie sind natürlich da und sie haben
sehr viele materieller Reserven von
etwas älterem Gerät aber doch noch
validengerät in Lagern gehabt die sie
offen war zum Teil zumindest reaktiviert
haben und die jetzt ins Gefecht geworfen
werden deswegen ist meine Befürchtung
dass tatsächlich die Ukraine sehr
vorsichtig sein sollten damit jetzt
qualitativ hochwertige Truppe Truppen
ausbluten zu lassen denn auch die Masse
hat eine eigene Qualität im Gefecht und
im Krieg insgesamt und da muss man schon
damit rechnen dass Russland jetzt in der
Lage ist eine große Gegend
offensichtlich führen die letzte Frage
von Ehrenamt Osterfest ja Entschuldigung
dass das kann natürlich einen Grund sein
warum man jetzt glaubt man muss bartmut
halten bis dann zwei panzerbatterione
kommen die dann das ganze wenden sollen
da würde ich aber eher vorsichtig sein
erstens werden sie nicht gleich in den
nächsten zehn Tagen kommen sondern das
wird auch noch ein paar Wochen dauern
bis sie dann wirklich vor Ort sind wir
reden hier über etwa 60 Leopard zwei
Panzer das ist keine strategische
Kriegswende das hilft natürlich vor Ort
taktisch enorm wenn die dann tatsächlich
im Verbund der Gift das Gefecht
verbundener Waffen arbeiten können aber
eine strategische Kriegswende ergibt
sich daraus nicht denn da muss man
natürlich den Gesamteinsatz der
Ressourcen sehen und da reden wir nicht
über 60 sondern da reden wir über 100
oder 1000 davon Kriegsgerät und das muss
man dann vergleich setzen
wir sprechen jetzt gleich noch mal über
die auch Hilfsleistungen auch aus
Deutschland an die Unterstützung die
dort geleistet wird aber vielleicht noch
mal allgemein die Frage zum Festhalten
der Ukraine an bachmut was den Westen
angeht könnte das ein Problem sein die
Äußerungen des US- teidigungsministers
Osten die Bedeutung der Stadt sei eher
symbolisch das ist jedenfalls in
deutschen Medien schon so interpretiert
worden dass das Kritik sei an der
ukrainischen Führung wie haben sie das
wahrgenommen
also erstens glaube ich dass
mittlerweile der Name bachmut aufgrund
des langen Kampfes den es eben Umbach
gut kam ergab tatsächlich eine
symbolische Bedeutung gekommen hat das
sollte aber nicht ablenken von den
operativen Gründen die es hier
tatsächlich gibt bachmut zu halten ist
ein Eckpfeiler der Verteidigung ich
sagte und wenn hier ein Durchbruch
passiert dann sind die Russen
wahrscheinlich sehr schnell 30 km weit
im offenen Gelände und stehen vor
Kameras dort ist das Hauptquartier der
der ukrainischen Kanadas der
ukrainischen aus Amerika dann was Armee
und dann wird es wirklich eng für die
Ukraine insofern verstehe ich natürlich
den Ansatz halten zu wollen aber die
Risiken sind enorm hoch wie Risiken der
Einkesselung die Risiken qualitativ
hochwertige getroffen zu verlieren und
das ist dann abzuwägen ich gedenke aber
wir sind ja etwas weit weg vom
gefechtgeschehen wir haben nicht alle
Informationen vor Ort ich denke der der
Genossenschaft
das sind bewusst und er wird vielleicht
so wie ins
auch rechtzeitig eine Entscheidung
treffen die Truppen zurückzusehen bevor
sie eingeschlossen werden wenn sie das
nicht tun würden dann droht allerdings
diesen Truppen das Schicksal von
mariopol und deswegen muss man jetzt ja
aufpassen ja eine Frage noch über
Youtube woher hat die Ukraine eigentlich
die ganze Munition wenn sie innerhalb
eines Tages die ganze Jahresproduktion
eines Landes verschießt haben die vor
dem Krieg so enorme Mengen gebunkert
aber das ist ja wenn ich das auch in den
letzten Wochen richtig verstanden habe
ein ganz normalischer Punkt die Munition
die fehlt oder zumindest bald zu fehlen
droht wie ist ihre Einschätzung dazu
also zunächst mal ist die Ukraine früher
ja zumindest der rüstungsstark gewesen
ein Drittel der sowjetischen
Rüstungsproduktion wurde in der Ukraine
hergestellt und entsprechend hat die
Ukraine diese Rüstungsbetriebe geerbt
sie ist in der Lage tatsächlich
hochwertige Güter zu produzieren das
haben wir gesehen bei den Raketen die
auch immerhin schon mittlere Reichweite
haben die dann einige spektakuläre
Ergebnisse erreicht haben aber sie haben
auch Panzer produziert und sie haben
auch sehr viel Munition produziert
natürlich durch den Krieg selbst sind
Verluste entstanden auch in der
Rüstungsproduktion die Angriffe auf die
Energie die russischen Angriffe auf die
Energie Lieferungen hat dazu beigetragen
dass ein Teil der Rüstungsindustrie auch
gelähmt worden ist und natürlich liegt
ein anderer Teil im Osten also ist unter
russischer Kontrolle das führt dazu dass
die Ukraine weniger Produkte produzieren
und es gibt ein zweites Argument je mehr
westliche Waffensysteme nach in die
Ukraine kommen umso mehr verlagert sich
auch die Last der Logistik auf den
Westen die Ukraine kann natürlich nicht
westliche Munition produzieren Karl
Leber sind hoffentlich anders die die
Produktionszeit ist anders und jetzt
geht es also im Westen darüber haben wir
diskutiert zum Beispiel um 155 mm
Granaten und nur mal eine Zahl zu nennen
in Deutschland wurde in einem halben
Jahr bis jetzt im Frieden also zumindest
so viel Artillerie Munition produziert
wie die Ukraine ein drei bis vier Tagen
verstehst das soll er sich natürlich
alles ändern im europäischen zusammen
Gang so dass mehr produziert wird aber
trotzdem ist schon klar dass man hier
wie auch der Bundeswehrverband ja
plötzlich deutlich gemacht hat in einer
Konkurrenzsituation ist denn
gleichzeitig muss ja auch der
kriegsvorrat der Bundeswehr aufgestockt
werden und das gilt für andere
europäische Armeen auch und hier ist das
Problem ich glaube schon dass man noch
in der Lage ist westliche Produktion so
oft zu fahren dass man die Ukraine
unterstützen kann aber man wird
vermutlich jedenfalls nicht in den
nächsten sechs sieben Monaten mithalten
können mit dem was die Russen noch am
Arbeiten haben und was sie mittlerweile
ja auch wieder trotz der Sanktionen eher
nicht wirklich nur wahr sind produzieren
kann ja was würde dann daraus folgen
daraus
Entschuldigung jetzt habe ich hier ja so
ja daraus folgt natürlich dass
einerseits die Frage sich stellt im
Westen kann man überhaupt auf ein die
Wirtschaft in kurzer Zeit auf
Kriegsproduktion umschalten damit ähm
hätte man natürlich wenn man das
vorausgesehen hätte sehr früh anfangen
müssen wenn man das jetzt tut wird das
Monate brauchen ist das überhaupt soweit
ist und die Frage stellt sich dann wie
viele Munition kann der Westen also an
die Ukraine liefern so dass sie diesen
Krieg wie äh unser Bundeskanzler stolz
sagt nicht verlieren die russischen
Angreifer ganz kurz wenn ich dann noch
mal einhaken darf die russischen
Angreifer in bachmut die setzen sich ja
zu einem Großteil aus Wagner Söldnern
zusammen die allerdings schon stark
dezimiert zu sein scheint jedenfalls
diejenigen unter Ihnen die aus den
Gefängnissen sozusagen rekrutiert worden
sind das ist ja auch ein erheblicher
Teil aber trotzdem welche Rolle kann und
wird diese Einheit jetzt noch in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen spielen im
Kampf aber auch darüber hinaus
ich glaube man muss das gesamte Bild von
Barut sehen natürlich im stadtkampf
selbst sind die wagnertruppen
vorherrschen aber sie sind nicht alleine
es gibt auch andere Truppen und wenn man
auf die Flügel schaut die in Norden und
im Süden an Bord vorbei gestoßen sind
dann sind das reguläre russische
Einheiten ich will auch nicht
in Frage stellen dass es möglicherweise
auch die ja doch ein Kämpfe gibt
zwischen den zwischen dem regulären
Militär und den wagnereinheiten und
insbesondere gewaschen aber das glaube
ich das Entscheidende ist da die
Gesamtwirkung die sich heraus ergibt ich
glaube man kann nicht sagen dass es
Wagner alleine ist die am Ende dann die
Entscheidung über bachmund Treffen
werden was mir aber auffällt ist dass in
der Tat die Wagner Truppen sozusagen die
Drecksarbeit in der Stadt machen also
von Haus zu Haus Kämpfen von Zimmer jede
Ruine wird ja da in wenigen in Kämpfen
von Tagen und da geht's nur um wenige
Meter voran genommen und da haben die
wagnergruppen in der Tatort Verluste ich
frag mich dann immer ob das nicht ein in
der russischen militärischen Führung gar
nicht so unnötig ist ja auch eine
interessante Frage Deutschland wird die
Ukraine mit 18 Leopard 2 Panzern
unterstützen noch im März sollen die
ukrainischen Soldaten die derzeit in
Deutschland an den Panzern ausgebildet
werden da haben wir auch Bilder zu in
die Ukraine mit dem Gerät zurückkehren
14 polnische Leopard 2 Panzer sind schon
in der Ukraine eingetroffen vielleicht
noch mal ganz kurz welche militärische
Bedeutung hat diese Unterstützung aus
Deutschland aber auch aus anderen
Staaten
also der erste Punkt ist dass man mal
nicht Taktik Operationsführung oder die
operative Ebene und Strategie
verwechseln soll wir reden hier immer
über ein paar Dutzend von Panzern wenn
es gut kommt aus ukrainischer Sicht dann
werden die deutschen gemeinsam mit
Schweden und Portugiesen ein
Panzerbataillon liefern das sind im nach
ukrainischen Rechnung 31 Kampfpanzer und
die das sind aber sehr moderne Panzer
also Leopard 2,6 dazu kommen die Polen
mit Leopard 2 A4 auch sehr gute Panzer
etwas Eltern nicht ganz so
fortgeschritten das sind also zwei
Bataillonen und das ist das was in der
überschaubaren Zeit also bis zum spät
früher früher und wirklich erscheinen
wird alles andere sind Ankündigungen die
also natürlich mehr Panzer auffassen
aber die nicht vor einigen Monaten
kommen mit anderen Worten zwei
Bataillone werden keine strategische
Wände bringen das ist völlig klar sie
werden allerdings helfen den Ukrainern
ihre Verteidigung zu stärken und sich
weiter eben zu halten gegenüber dem
schon Angriffen aber wir müssen dann
immer die die Zahlen auch im Vergleich
sind früher gab es ja die
kräftevergleiche am kalten krieg ich
sehe im Moment keine mehr aber das wäre
wichtig mal zu vergleichen was das
bedeutet 60 Kampfpanzer gegen einige
Hundert oder vielleicht sogar mehr als
1000 die von der russischen Seite kommt
da vielleicht auch gerade noch mal die
Nachfrage also ziel ist es ja auch
irgendwann eine Gegenoffensive zu
starten seitens der Ukraine auch dafür
nehme ich an sollen die Panzer
eingesetzt werden vielleicht noch mal
für den Leim weil man liest auch immer
wieder es wäre momentan schwierig
überhaupt mit Panzern voranzukommen zu
viel Matsch und so weiter aber wenn man
jetzt diese hoch modernen Geräte sieht
dann denkt man ja die kommen durch alles
durch wie wie ist das kann man momentan
eine offensive eine gegen Offensive
starten
ja gut das ist natürlich teilweise
tagesabhängig das hängt sehr vom Wetter
ab das Gelände ist relativ offen es ist
landwirtschaftlich genutzt also Umbach
zwischen bachmuttern kann man Torsten
wenn Sie das Gelände machen und wenn es
dann feucht wird ist das natürlich
teilweise schwierig weil gibt's viele
kleinere Gräben die damit Wasser gefüllt
sind generell kommt natürlich ein Panzer
durch aber wenn so ein größeres Gelände
nur ganz sumpfig ist dann wird es auch
für gepanzerte Verbände schwierig und
das ist aber nicht die vorherrschende
Lage die dann über Tage andauert sondern
das ändert sich natürlich auch und wenn
es dann etwas Trockner wird dann kann
man natürlich mit solchen Verbänden
durchkommen ich glaube das Wetter ist
dann nur vorübergehend einfach Faktor
noch eine Frage anderer Punkt God of War
keine Richter etwas zum Abschluss der
amerikanischen Drohne sagen vielleicht
noch mal ganz kurz eine Abschluss in dem
Sinne war das nicht ich fasse das gerade
noch mal zusammen also über dem
Schwarzen Meer sind offenbar eine
US-Drohne und eine russische Kampfjet
kollidiert die Amerikaner mussten
daraufhin ihre Drohne zum Absturz
bringen beklagen sich jetzt über das
Verhalten der Russen betonen aber
gleichzeitig auch an sich sein solche
Manöver jetzt nicht ungewöhnlich was ist
von diesem Vorgang zu halten
also zunächst mal müssen wir festhalten
es ist ganz entscheidend wo dieser
Abschuss oder diese dieser Zwischenfall
ist sogar kein abschlussdam direkt oder
dieser Zwischenfall stattgefunden hat
aus dem Wäldern die ich bisher habe
entnehme ich dass es in der Nähe im
Schwarzen Meer aber in der Nähe des
ukrainischen und russischen Luftraumes
ist daraus kann man eigentlich nur
ableiten dass es irgendwo im Bereich von
gertstein musste denn wenn beide
Lufträume also aneinander angrenzen dann
könnt auch aus europäischen
amerikanischer Sicht würde er dann die
quasi ukrainisches Gebiet sein und dann
wäre es dieser Luftraum genau weiß ich
nicht wo stattgefunden hat so Routine es
ist ganz normal dass man also auch im
Vorfeld des nationalen Hoheitsgebietes
und der erschreckt sich ja dann immerhin
auch noch 12 Seemann in Richtung offene
See dass man auch jenseits beobachtet
was die gegnerische Seite jeweils tut
das tun wir auch das tun alle
NATO-Staaten auch wenn russische Flieger
oder Nordsee fliegen dann werden diese
Pfleger beobachtet man begleitet sie
sollten Sie sich richtig Richtung
nationaler Luftraum bewegen dann gibt es
ab also gewisse Zeichen die man dann
versteht dass man mit den Flügeln wackel
und zeigt man hat Bewaffnung und das
findet in der Regel dann auch nicht
statt also das ist das abdrängen das ist
eigentlich ein routinevorgang das hätte
hier auch so sein können es ist
natürlich schwierig eine Drohne
abzudrängen da müssen die braunen
Piloten die ganz ferne irgendwo in
irgendwelchen Kommandozentralen weit
absetzen müssen darauf reagieren wenn
Sie diesen Überblick haben das ist sehr
sehr schwer dazu kommt dass diese Reaper
Drohne die es sich anscheinend handelt
nicht nur eine aufklärungsfunktion hat
sondern eben auch eine eine bewaffnete
Drohne ist oder zumindest sein kann die
dann auch Kampfaufträge hat das hat sie
wahrscheinlich nicht gehabt Amerikaner
nicht haben Kampf teilnehmen aber was
die Russen davon gehalten haben ist mir
nicht bekannt vielleicht gab es ja eine
Fehleinschätzung kann schon sein und ein
zweiter Punkt kommt dazu auf der
hausergebnisse die die Amerikaner dort
gewinnen werden ja über alle wissen
letztlich an die Ukraine weitergegeben
also das sind alles Punkte die natürlich
die Russen sehr betreffen und insofern
haben Sie möglicherweise hier auch
tatsächlich überreagiert das sind nicht
die Standards und nicht die
internationalen Regeln aber man müsste
hier mehr wissen insbesondere wo es
genau stattgefunden hat okay verstehe
gut also dann hoffen wir mal dass dieser
Vorgang dieser Vorfall uns noch nicht
den unmittelbaren Angstschweiß auf die
Stirn drei muss aber man liest sowas
natürlich immer mit großer Sorge das
waren natürlich
wichtig ist ist dass man die
eskalationsmechanismus hat man braucht
also zum Beispiel zwischen dem
militärischen Hauptquartieren heiße
Drähte um in solchen Fällen wenn es also
solche Zwischenfälle gibt sofort zu
sagen das war nicht beabsichtigt und um
SD eskalierende Maßnahmen eben
einzuladen damit es nicht dazu kommt
dass sie jetzt gerade gesagt haben was
natürlich sehr berechtigt ist dass das
dann eskalieren kann das waren die sehr
kenntnisreichen Einschätzungen von von
Wolfgang Richter Militärexperte und
Oberst ade ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie
sich die Zeit heute Abend für uns
genommen haben Dankeschön sehr gerne
Erwärmung danke und ja an euch natürlich
auch ganz herzlichen Dank für eure
Fragen und Kommentare zur Situation rund
um bachmut wir wünschen euch einen
schönen Abend trotz des schweren Themas
und würden uns freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten Mal auch wieder dabei seid bis
dann ciao ciao